what are you doing you're a governor and
you get this edict from the president's
open your church as well if you are Ohio
Governor Mike DeWine Don you've never
closed them down or shut them down or or
restricted their use he joins us right
now governor very good to have you again
good to see you Neal thank you very much
could you explain now I believe and I
don't want to put this or characterize
it incorrectly you have always seen
churches places of worship as essential
businesses that can't be shuttered but
I'm sure you have rules in place because
there they obviously attract large
gatherings what are they in Ohio what
would change under this eating good
anything well we've always exempted
churches synagogues places of worship
from any of our orders
you know we've said very clearly that
our suggestion is that people be
exceedingly careful you know not have
big big congregations gathering together
closely in many churches the Catholic
Church whose diocese for example in Ohio
I think all the bishops canceled
you know if canceled services for for
some time they're going to be opening up
shortly other churches have come up with
amazing ways to do it
they've even used you know drive-in
movie theaters for people to go come
into and have services they've done them
virtually so they've done it really a
great job a lot of the churches I know
now are planning to start opening back
up again and you know they're they're
coming up with good ways of doing that
we just encourage the the churches to be
just very very careful it's like any
other gathering together you know try to
keep that that distance we've asked you
know suggested not told but suggested
that you know people were masked and
they just try to get that extra layer of
protection Temenos I mean I'm your
continuing easing up on restrictions the
latest is a you know fall sports
training can resume I believe on June
1st you're also looking at banquets even
though it's for weddings
crowds don't exceed 300 what else am I
missing or what else you doing well you
know yesterday was the first day that
we've had you know this latter part of
this week the first couple of days that
we've had the opening of restaurants and
bars inside and I just looked at a
report a moment ago in regard to the
bars and most of we're doing pretty well
last night we had to you know remind a
few of kind of what the orders were but
the report was very good I got a report
from a number of bars around the state
three or four hundred and it was it was
a good report so we just remind people
be careful the virus is still out there
we got do two things at once we got to
open up our economy we're doing that but
we got to remain safe all right because
I thought of the 300 figure governor and
I come from an Italian family 300 is
just small you might have yeah you might
have issues with that let me switch
gears go ahead and finish that though
well I'm just going to say that you know
we've exempted weddings and funerals
the real question there was the wedding
reception and you know caterers came to
us and said look we've got a facility we
can run this just like a restaurant and
we can have the space and so what we've
said is you know up to 300 you can do
but again you've got to follow the
spacing you got to do the same things
that we're requiring of restaurants to
do I know a lot of it's very
common-sense stuff um let me ask you a
little bit right now this comes at a
time where a lot of states are being
scrutinized that the reopening and
whether it it is jiving with numbers
that support the reopening in other
words not an unusual spike in cases or
that the percentage of those testing
positive of the virus remains low I
believe but CDC recommendations governor
you know these better than I recommended
no higher than 3% I don't know
specifically what they are in Ohio but
what would make you slow that down what
would give you pause in this process
well you know we're watching numbers
that are published all the time for
example
traffic our traffic in Ohio was down 50%
at one point we're now down about ten so
you're seeing people really starting to
move around a lot and so you know that's
something that we got a we got a watch
if they do it correctly and if people
continue to do the spacing you know
that's fine but we also know that that
the risk goes up you know as far as the
specific numbers one of the numbers we
look at is number of hospital admissions
that has been pretty flat we plateau
that out it's not going down but it's
not going up that's been steady for
about a month so we'll keep an eye on
that we'll also keep an eye on what I
refer to as the replication rate
basically if I have a Koba 19 how many
people on average does that person in
fact and at one point in Ohio we were 1
to 2 and so that's not good that's you
know at dramatic spread we're now down
to 1 to 1 and so we're going to keep our
eye on that as we open up society and
you know we don't want that to creep up
very very high because that'll be that
means that we're going out faster than
we were and and you know in 3 or 4 weeks
after that you know we're gonna start to
see these numbers spiked up so we're
careful we've done this with what we
consider to be the best practices
restaurant people got together we put
restaurant people with health people
they came up with best practices did the
same thing people who run bars people
who cut hair you know so we've come up
with what we think is are the best
practices but Ohioans we just need to
stay focused we can do two things at
once but we got to be careful
all right continued good health good
luck with all of this governor very good
seeing you again thanks Neal which
governor Mike DeWine I'm one of the
earliest to act on shutting down his
state or at least shutting down a lot
more of what had been going on in his
state long before we even had the worry
or the incidence of cases it was proven
very prescient on that front